moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le crooner
à l'ambassade ainsi expliqué expliqué a
déjà bon alors non on expliquait pas
regarder une image vaut mille mots vas-y
ce serait vrai
[Musique]
courageux
soit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par dessus
d'accord on vous a pris une baisse avec
des épaulettes comme à l'époque
oui c'est vrai mais ils s'en souviennent
la chanson par coeur mais ce que je
voudrais moi ce qui m a le regard et on
regarde on y ténébreux me fais la gueule
quand même vers la sicile est à côté de
moi sera plus facile pour vous habiller
oui jean-luc jonathan qui s'habillent
donner les chiffres de ventes de singles
peut-être qu'on était alors alors l'
époque là aussi c'était plus facile de
vendre et moi voyez beaucoup à la télé
et c'était quoi ces petites attitudes
nous refaire latitude avec la main dans
la folle quand j'avais un peu de mal à
assumer ce titre qui était sympathique
certes mais qui est épaté québec où
j'étais extrêmement alors sont des
copains de bordeaux d'accord comme je
passe à la télé les copains et ramé à
bordeaux il m'a dit on va atterrir un
titre et comme tu es connu tubes à le
chanter
j'étais tellement ça balance
est-ce qu'on peut remettre le playback
et refaites mots justes l'attitude non
mais faites nous plaisir
[Musique]
micro comme ça
le
qu'aujourd'hui
merde
non merci c'est à ces dames ont tous la
corée relancer les ventes de ce soir on
va surveiller en streaming foot ya
quelque chose dans les poubelles
oui les musiques dans bien des musiciens
c'est bien comme ça en plus on se dit
tout pour retrouver ses biens sait pas
encore quand même un peu
moi j'aime beaucoup la chanson le pauvre
jean fort non c'était la mode à l'époque
ça